Showtime such scope to the reaction in  this room it is extraordinarily grand I  think for audience is seeing a movie  like IMAX on the big screen you're gonna  have a hugely immersive experience  you're gonna see something that you've  never seen before we never see what we  put ourselves through alone just to get  this screens is remarkable I think the  IMAX experience is kind of the ultimate  cinematic experience I think senior IMAX  theaters you're gonna feel like you  really be here I think was now made for  IMAX it's just create the illusion of  massive it's incredible yes it's  definitely our Max is definitely a  natural home for this summing up the  IMAX experience in three was a beautiful  get bigger bigger extravagant explosive  mind-blowing  really really big  you